discours d'ouverture assez long assez
académique nous allons vous en parler
avec les détails ce qu'il faut retenir
en deux mots la rigueur budgétaire le
québec selon fait le brouillard est au
bord d'un précipice si on ne resserre
pas de façon vigoureuse les finances
publiques ce qu'a vu ce que ça veut dire
en deux mots des choix difficiles comme
nous dit martin biron c'est un moment
solennel officiel le moment où le
premier ministre dévoile les intentions
de son gouvernement pour la durée de son
mandat sa priorité redresser les
finances publiques
il faut agir de façon ferme et décisive
nous le ferons leurs graves dit le
premier ministre les élastiques de
l'endettement et de la fiscalité ont été
tirés au maximum nous devons nous
libérer de la menace qui enchaîne notre
liberté de faire des choix
si rien n'est fait le déficit budgétaire
du québec dépassera les 5 milliards de
dollars en 2014 2015
des compressions ont déjà été annoncées
pour contenir le déficit
il propose de mettre en place deux
grandes commissions la première reverra
le système fiscal des particuliers
il raconte là dessus l'histoire d'un
entrepreneur lorsqu'une de ses employés
avaient refusé une augmentation de
salaire car disent elles ça n'en valait
pas la peine
d'autres ailleurs me l'ont répété et si
on faisait le calcul on s'apercevrait
malheureusement c'est vrai les
entreprises ou s'ils seront touchés le
régime de soutien aux entreprises sera
revue en profondeur les sommes
importantes qui sont consacrés ne donne
clairement pas le niveau de résultat
souhaité la deuxième commission celle
qui risque d'être la plus douloureuse
passera au peigne fin tous les
programmes de l'état
mais on sait sur le président que dans
ce genre d'action les consensus sont
difficiles le gouvernement écoutera les
divers points de vue mais agira de façon
nette et décisive
certains programmes disparaîtront
d'autres seront modifiés il prévoit un
dialogue animé est difficile mais l'état
a dit le premier ministre
n'a plus les moyens de ses ambitions à
qui ou à quelle génération allons nous
renvoyer la facture si nous n'agissons
pas tous les secteurs tous les
ministères ils passeront a dit le
premier ministre en éducation en santé
ou si les réformes seront difficiles la
façon d'accéder à ce rêve de réaliser
nos ambitions passe par un travail
difficile exigeant suivant un grand la
culture de l'état doit changer a dit le
premier ministre qui prédit une période
difficile jusqu'à l'atteinte de
l'équilibré budgétaire en 2015 2016
après il entrevoit une accalmie des
jours plus prospères ici martin biron
radio canada québec lui des bons madame
marois et j'ai trouvé ça correct
j'ai vu aussi qu'il souhaitait continuer
la politique de l'éducation les
transports
il ya peut-être eu la mauvaise mère ou
la mauvaise d'éternité mais pour le
reste ce sont les propos leurs proches
c'est bien projet du parti québécois
l'atteinte de l'équilibré budgétaire en
2015 2016 est rigoureusement est
possible à moins de couper largement
dans les dépenses publiques et ça va
faire mal au niveau des services à la
population
je vous souligne qu'il n'y a pas eu un
mot sur la question de la réduction des
inégalités
on aurait mieux entendre la bouche
communiste réduction des taxes on l'a
mentionné du côté de monsieur legault on
aurait aimé voir la taxe santé aboli sur
eux libres pour les personnes qui
gagnent 40 5000 $ et moins on aurait
aimé aussi voir l'augmentation des
tarifs plus drôle est restée réduite de
4 points seront à deux points de
pourcent de donner de l'oxygène aux
familles québécoises
la première chose que je remarque c'est
on veut redonner cette autonomie aux
municipalités
aujourd'hui on a envoyé un message très
clair qu'on ne parle plus maintenant de
créatures des provinces on parle de deux
ordres de gouvernement de proximité sur
cet essentiel c'est important dans un
contexte de création de richesse
on comprend que la métropole dans un
rôle important que nous avons capitale
nationale mais qu'il faut définir dans
ce contexte économique un statut pour
les métropoles de montréal